a manhunt is under way for the gunman
who opened fire at an off-campus College
party in Texas the shooting early
yesterday killed two people and hurt 12
others and a vigil last night for one of
the victims was interrupted by more
gunfire dramatic cell phone video video
captured the chaos inside the party
Mireya Villarreal is in Greenville Texas
near the scene of the first shooting
Maria have any suspects been identified
at this point we know Anthony right now
we do not know who is responsible for
either shooting but this is where the
first one happened and as the shooter
fired off his gun partygoers streamed
out of the building that you see right
behind me
hundreds of them running for their lives
with just two exits to choose from there
was another shooting in Texas last night
this time at a vigil as family and
friends gathered in Dallas to remember
23 year old Kevin berry jr. one of the
alleged victims of a homecoming party
shooting early Sunday morning Berry was
allegedly one of two people killed at an
off-campus party in Greenville Texas
near the Texas A&M university-commerce
campus horrific cell phone video
captured the shooting as it was
happening 12 other people were injured
six of them have gunshot wounds
[Applause]
investigators believe this shooter came
into the building through a back door
and may have targeted someone at the
party but deputies say they are not sure
because some witnesses are not
cooperating I don't know if they're
afraid if they're afraid of being
retaliated against we really need people
to come forward
more than 750 people were at the party
at the time of the shooting
investigators say the gunman was able to
get away by blending in with the large
crowd during the panic and the chaos the
suspects our suspects were able to flee
the scene and we were working on
identifying them at this point Ciera
VTOL was at the homecoming party and
says she has a personal connection to
some of the victims it's kind of sad
knowing that we were here like coming to
like celebrate something and then like
something like this happens but I mean I
guess this is just the world that we
live in now
the local sheriff's department tells me
they are monitoring the shooting that
happened at the vigil in Dallas in the
meantime they have the FBI and the ATF
here in Greenville Texas helping with
this investigation Tony
Maria thank you very much